- There's gonna be drama, there's gonna be games,
there's gonna be music, there's gonna be-
- Oh god.
- It's an event. Since the day I was alive,
my cookouts have never been chill.
(smooth electronic music)
- Well, a cookout to me is like
^where black people come to be black-ity black black.
^- All the generations get together.
^- All of 'em.
^- And it's the one place where you can like
teach the older generation as much as they teach you too.
- True.
^- A cookout is a safe place to be around friends and family.
^- A cookout is the only place
^where you don't have to color switch.
^- It's immediate family, it's siblings, aunts, uncles,
^cousins, neighbors, family friends,
^fake aunties, fake uncles.
- It was my Haitian education school.
That's where I learned about my culture, my music,
how to cook, the importance of family members.
- Yeah, you can't fight at a cookout.
- People fight at the cookout.
- You can't, you not supposed to.
^- Let's see what celebs are coming to our cookouts.
^- Hell nah, I can tell you that from the jump.
^The whole Kardashian clan.
^- She'd be too much of a spectacle.
^Like the grandmas wouldn't stop talking about her.
^- The cornrows, I'm not with it.
^You not about to be at my family cookout embarrassing me.
^- Hell nah, but then I'm gonna go like this.
She can come to the parking lot to drop off the baby.
- I'm doing this for her sake
because my family is very intense.
My family will just like talk crap and like laugh
and like joke and for some people it's pretty intense.
- And you know that they're not bringing nothing to help out
and you're not taking no plates home with you.
Like none of that, none of that.
^- You not taking none of my plates. (laughs)
^- I'm a have to go with a no for Justin Timberlake.
^- Justin Timberlake, you on the outside brah brah.
^- There would be peas in his potato salad.
^(Kiano laughs)
^- I'd be like can I do this one.
^- No, halfway, right.
^- Post cornrows, pre this last album,
^Justin was cool, you know.
- Let me tell you why you can't come to the cookout,
in my opinion.
- Cause I know exactly what you about to say.
- You know what I'm about to say.
^- No, I take it back, no, no, no.
^- No?
^- After that Janet situation,
^I'm not friends with him anymore.
^- Oh, you're right, yeah, the Janet situation.
^- Yeah.
^- You can't come to the cookout
^if you not protecting black women.
^- You can't.
- You knew what you did, right, you knew what you,
you knew, you was a part of it.
- Yeah.
^- Not my cookout.
^- Why would you even ask me that?
^Why is that even an option?
- Rachel went around masquerading as a black woman.
^You sued a university for reverse racism, we don't do that.
^You're out.
^- But be yourself at the end of the day.
^We can't say today I wanna be black, today,
^you know, I don't wanna be, we can't do that.
- Black people discriminating against white people
doesn't prevent white people from housing opportunities,
job opportunities, living, literally being alive.
- They all know who she is
and you don't want no Haitian on their bad side.
^- I don't believe in encouraging bad behavior.
^- Yeah.
^- It's a no, but I'll make her a plate. (laughs)
^- Him and his kids can totally come to my cookout, even Kim.
- She can't come, your kids can come.
- Yeah, the cookout will be when she's out of town.
^- The whole Kardashian clan, Kanye included.
^- Kanye needs some of that food
^to pull him out of the sunken place.
- Isn't that against the rules of cookout,
you can't invite part of the family,
it's invite the whole family.
If you say no to Kylie, how can you have Kanye?
^- Greatest of all time.
^- Kanye must be one of the greatest of all time.
- Old kanye can come to the cookout.
- Kanye, come as you are
and we will send you out as you should be.
- They all would not come to my cookout.
- That is like a third rule of cookout,
you invite the whole family.
- See, well, in mine,
it's discouraged to bring some members.
Do they come, yes. Is there drama, always.
^- Because the sister-in-law can't come, Kanye can't come.
^- She's so nice.
- Hell nah.
^That's it, that's all I got to say.
^- Nope.
- Omarosa at one point was very like pro-black women.
^Her rooting for Trump mitigated everything that she
^ever worked toward regarding,
^- Mitigating, yes.
^- Right, regarding black women, I just, take it all the way.
^- Why!
^- Omarosa has like a whole purview of
^insight into a different view for my family,
^therefore it could make for a very interesting conversation.
- You accepted that invitation to that White House,
you declined your invitation to the cookout.
- We'll have to see, like, 2020 cookout maybe you can come.
- Right, no, she can't.
- She can like the picture on Instagram.
- Right, she can like the Instagram pic, right.
We not gon' block her, she can see the pic, yeah.
^- Yeah, she can see.
- I feel like she's a really nice person.
^I can see her like sitting around chatting to my Grandma.
^You know, I feel like she would be very
^engaged and interested.
^- You can't, you can't just kind of
^take advantage of our culture when you need it
^and then shit on it the next day.
^- Because you're putting on the culture as a costume
^when it's beneficial to you,
^when it stops being beneficial to you, you take it off.
^- Non-POC people kinda like to
^show that they know black people.
^I don't want my family and my name to just be
^poster childs, no.
- She used it to get ahead and then she was like,
'Actually, I wanna be myself again.'
- Right.
- And so what about Juicy J?
^- All these dudes that look like idiots now.
^- I just watched a video about is he appropriating or not.
^Like maybe, this is my answer.
^- He appreciates, he doesn't appropriate.
^He gives credit where credit is due.
- I know Bruno gonna kill it when we start dancing you know.
^- A hundred percent.
^I wish you gonna do it, Bruno.
^Watch your drunk uncle do the electric slide.
^- My family does not dance at the cookout
and I feel like he can make it happen.
- Everybody he puts on is black,
he makes music with black artists.
- Right.
- Bruno good with me.
- He good with me.
- I'm good with Bruno.
- I'm good.
- I love cookouts, I want a cookout right now.
- It's a good unwind from the busy busy of day-to-day life.
- Paramore's in there.
- Paramore can definitely come.
- Paramore is in the cookout, for sure.
- Hayley Williams is my girl.
- [Tristan] Paramore's in the cookout, for sure.
- [Sequoia] Hayley coming, yeah.
(light music)
- [Sequoia] Can Dr. Phil come?
No.
- [Tristan] Nah.
- [Sequoia] No.
- He can't come, Ianna can't come either.
We're not fixing no lives at the cookout.
- Oh my god.